[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm qHD here and
welcome to the Q&A video number three
for 2017 it kind of figured we're doing
these on a monthly basis now there is
one in January one in February and now
it's March so before it snows us in here
go ahead answer some questions from
Twitter if you think Apple and Google
are collaborating on something referring
to Tim Cook and perch Ives dinner I
don't know if you guys saw there is this
picture floating around of sundar pichai
the CEO of Google and Tim Cook the CEO
of Apple at some dinner maybe I can't
even talk during the same place the
photo looks weird it looks almost
photoshopped like the angles are messed
up but you know what even if we take the
picture of face value it is totally
possible they have dinner together one
day and someone took a photo of it I
don't know if they're collaborating on
something because they had dinner
together but I still would love to
imagine like I'd love to be a fly on the
wall for that conversation
all right you know how it goes first one
to smile picks up the top for dinner
right
whoo you should update the Mac bro what
is the worst thing you've ever done at a
tech event I actually thought about this
one for a little while and I couldn't
come up with anything but then I read
the replies to this tweet and actually
brought up a good one there was once a
moto X launch event in New York City and
instead of bringing the typical camera
that I usually do
I brought the rx100 is one of the first
point shoots at the time to shoot 4k
video it was an opportunity to test it
so I like a really good use for that
camera and I brought it in to get the
first hands-on for that new Moto X and
get footage on the rx100 well that was
when I very quickly learned that that
camera overheats while shooting 4k for
more than about five to eight minutes at
a time so I was stuck in that event with
a brand new phone in my hand and a
camera that stopped working five minutes
into my shooting because I had to take
out the battery and would you literally
blow on it to get it to cool down but
luckily I had a couple batteries with me
I could go through them and cool down
the camera and get all my footage but
that was almost a lot worse than it
actually ended up being I mean the video
I got out of it actually ended up being
pretty good but that might be the worst
thing worst thing I've ever done at a
tech event if you could meet one person
dead or alive and talk tech with them
for an hour who would it be
okay so brace yourself for the most
unsurprising answer in the world I'm
pretty sure this would be on anyone's
list probably in their top three or five
at least would be Elon Musk I've
interviewed a couple people in the past
and they weren't necessarily tech
specific figures you saw the video I did
with Kobe I tried to ask him about tech
it was clearly not a huge tech head I've
even talked with Neil deGrasse Tyson
who's an astrophysicist but we talked
more about like conceptual stuff but if
you've ever seen Elon Musk get
interviewed he was the CEO of an
electric car company and he can
literally give specifics about
fine-tuning the ostrich cars motors and
the aerodynamics and the technology that
goes inside it all that stuff same thing
with rockets he happens to also run a
rocket company and talk specifics about
rocket science so I think it'd be pretty
awesome to talk tech with Elon Musk for
like an hour even if we're just shooting
about like it what phone do you use like
what tab would you use what laptop do
you use have you taken the challenge of
making a Tesla Model S commercial so for
those who haven't seen a Elon Musk of
all people the CEO of Tesla retweeted
tweet from apparently a letter he got
from a five-year-old asking if they
could hold a contest to make the best
video about Tesla and they wouldn't have
to spend any money on marketing because
that's kind of a thing Tesla doesn't do
but they could give some prize to the
winter so now hustles actually doing it
it's called Project love day I think
that's the name of the little girl's
last name and I'll link it below I'll
link to tweet so you can see the whole
story that led up to it but now they're
opening submissions for the best
possible video in under 90 seconds about
Teslas of course naturally I'm thinking
about making maybe not just one video
but maybe I'll make a couple of
submissions and like put them in to one
video that I put on YouTube but also
submit them separately so they can get
those I think it'll be a lot of fun to
try to make the best most clever
possible video about the Model S
considering the ability we have to do
that I don't know if you guys have any
ideas for what I should put in the video
here's one why don't you talk about
sponsors in your videos video the simple
answer to that is usually because there
is no sponsor if there ever is a sponsor
it's actually legally required that I
disclose it so that will always be
either in like the bottom corner of the
video you'll see that there's paid
promotion in a video but that's very
rare and in fact the last sponsored
video that I've done I actually had to
look it up was the 101 plus 3t giveaway
a naturally on a tech channel you always
think like oh if he shows a product or
if he likes a product that's clearly
helping the company that made the
product out a little bit which is also
the reason why anytime I like something
I get accused of being paid for it but
obviously you know I can't do that
because that's illegal like super
illegal so the one reason we actually do
like to bring in sponsors for videos is
to be able to make things happen that we
couldn't ordinarily do sometimes it's to
get access to something like a product
to show you where sometimes it's to give
away a hundred phones I'm pretty sure it
would have been extremely difficult for
me to buy a hundred phones and then give
them all away and then ship them all
internationally to the winners that
would been impossible without the
sponsors so that's the type of thing
that I look to go to a sponsor for is to
make stuff happen that couldn't
ordinarily happen if you guys are ever
at all curious about whether or not a
device was provided for the video that I
made about it you can always find that
at the bottom of the description so if
you see a review and you just want to
know that's always going to be there you
see smartwatches making a comeback in
2017 no not really I kind of see it the
same way that tablets ended up tablets I
made a video about if they're dying or
not I think they kind of are if it's not
an iPad it's kind of falling off the map
in the tablet world I mean let's be real
and it's kind of the same way
smartwatches are now if it's not an
Apple watch it's kind of off
upon off the map which is pretty sad
that doesn't mean there aren't other
good smartwatches out there because
there are there's really good
smartwatches
but in terms of sales volume brand
awareness just people knowing about
smartwatches pebble is gone all like a
ton of the ones that we used to really
put our name on like the Moto 360 that's
gone it's the Apple watch or is nothing
that's just the way it is plus
predictions for those Clippers uh not
looking too high I mean it's still like
middle of the West but I'll say we will
lose to either the Warriors or the Spurs
where we play first because being a
youtuber a career or a hobby what is
your favorite meme at the moment awesome
says if you could redo one video from
the last eight years which would it be
first of all Wow eight years have we
been making videos for eight years
second of all I almost have no good
answer for this the one thing I can say
is I did get to interview Kobe a while
ago if I could redo that and meet Kobe
again that would be pretty cool what do
you expect from the pixel - okay so we
know the pixel one the Google pixel was
a surprise great phone from last year
and we're kind of all but confirmed that
we're going to see a pixel - this year
what do I expect from it I have almost
no clue all I know is stock Android the
latest version there's people outside
talking the designs we've seen from
phones if you're already like the g6
with that great display and no bezel and
also the Galaxy s8 coming kind of have
me optimistic for probably a little bit
of a more radical design for the pixel
but again that the focus of the pixel
has never really been designed I mean
you go back to the Nexus it's all about
the software so it's kind of a toss-up
we'll see I'll be happy to see anyway
that's where I'm gonna end this QA thank
you so much for your questions and for
your comments of course I'm looking
forward to and if you want to be first
in line to be able to ask questions for
the next Q&A if you just want to see
when it's happening be sure to follow on
Twitter the link is below that's where
I'll end it thanks for watching talk to
guys the next one
[Music]